so here's a pink ball rolling toward a
green cube
that's sitting at rest on a frictionless
surface when the pink ball
hits and slams into the green cube it's
going to exert a force
to the right on the green cube and the
green cube's going to speed up
but because of newton's third law
whatever force the pink
ball exerts on the green cube to the
right has to be equal and opposite
to the force the green cube exerts
backward
on the pink ball so the green cube's
going to gain some momentum
but the pink ball is going to lose some
momentum and here's the cool thing
whatever momentum is gained by this
green cube has to be the same amount of
momentum that's lost by the pink ball
so if the green cube gained three units
of momentum to the right
then the pink ball has to lose three
units of momentum to the right
and this is true whether these are the
same mass or different masses or whether
the green cube was moving left to start
or right to start however they collide
if two objects collide
the change in momentum between the two
objects has to be
equal and opposite and this is why we
love momentum whatever momentum's gained
by one
has to be lost by the other and so how
is that possible you might be like how
can that work well let's go up here
think about these forces the forces on
each object are equal and opposite
here's the cool part though the time
they're in contact
also has to be equal because as soon as
one of them loses contact with the other
the other loses contact with the one and
in physics
force times time is called the impulse
now
this is the change in momentum this will
equal the change in momentum so if you
want to know how much momentum was
gained
by this green cube multiply the force
exerted on it by the time
you'll get the change in momentum of the
green cube that's true for this pink
ball and look
the force is backwards just the negative
of this
other impulse so this is why the pink
ball
no matter what its mass or how fast it's
going same with green cube
these changes in momentum must be equal
and opposite
simply due to newton's third law so to
be clear what i'm saying is this if you
were to graph the momentum
this pink ball would have started off
with some momentum and that would have
been constant before the collision if
there's no friction or air resistance
but then it lost some momentum so this
goes down and maybe end up right here
and then afterward
it'll maintain a constant amount of
momentum the green
box the green cube here started with
zero momentum it was at rest
during this collision it gained some
momentum so it's going to jump up maybe
to here
what i'm saying is that and afterward it
stays constant
what i'm saying is that these two jumps
are the same you know if this thing
lost let's say it lost four units of
momentum
well then this green cube has to gain
four units of momentum
and you might be like okay i don't care
but here's why you should care if you
were to graph the total
momentum what this means is that the
total momentum which was just the pink
ball initially is going to remain
constant the whole time it's as if
the momentum never realized a collision
occurred
this total momentum just remains
constant
and this is why conservation of momentum
is a thing is why it's really useful
the total initial momentum in a system
even if a collision occurs between
objects in that system
the total initial momentum must be equal
to the total
final momentum as long as the forces are
only
internal that is to say between objects
in the system
and there's no external forces then this
will always be true so this is a super
powerful
tool we can use to problem solve this
saves us a lot of time and trouble
if a collision is occurring this is one
of our best methods to solve for things
is
conservation of momentum now keep in
mind even though the total momentum in a
system has to stay the same
the momentum of an individual object
does not have to stay the same these
objects can exchange momentum
but again the reason this is going to be
conserved is that
they do so equally if one gains five the
other loses five and so on
and the total amount stays the same so
let me show you how this works real
quick so just give an idea numerically
here
so let's say the pink ball was two
kilograms and it was going five meters
per second to start
and the green cube had a mass m and
afterward
let's say the pink ball is going four
meters per second so it's slowed down
and the green cube speeds up let's say
it's going eight meters per second
you might think wait this isn't
conserved the pink ball only lost
one five to four but the green cube
gained
eight but remember we're not conserving
velocity we're conserving
momentum so momentum is m times v
momentum is m v and it's a vector got to
be careful has a direction
so i'm not saying the amount of velocity
is conserved or anything like that i'm
saying momentum is conserved
so what i'm saying is that p initial
total has to equal
p final total so only the pink ball had
moment
momentum initially so it had two two
kilograms
times five meters per second of momentum
to start with the green cube had none so
this has got it equal
afterward the pink ball has two
kilograms times
four meters per second and the green
cube does have momentum
afterward now we gotta add it up this is
gonna be the total momentum so plus
mass of the cube times its eight meters
per second
well so this isn't too hard the math
here is easy so there's going to be 10
units of momentum 10
kilogram meters per second is what the
ball started with
and then the ball is going to end with 8
kilogram meters per second
so we can see right here the ball lost 2
units of momentum
that means the green cube better gain
two units of momentum so it's gonna be
plus
m times eight and so this is what i mean
when this can help you solve problems we
can just solve for the mass now now we
can know what the mass of the cube had
to be
so 10 minus eight is going to be 2 units
is how much momentum
this green cube has to gain and if we
divide 2 by 8
we get that the mass of the green cube
had to be
0.25 kilograms so indeed if we took the
0.25
kilograms times the 8 that this cube
ended with
0.25 times 8 really does give us 2
positive 2. it gained
2 units of momentum this is why
momentum is conserved whatever gain and
momentum one thing gets
there's a corresponding loss in the
other and so
this is going to be equal now how could
you ever make it so that this was
not equal well this will always be equal
if the only forces being exerted are
internal to your system
the only way you make this non-equal is
to have external forces so what would
that look like well imagine
the ball in the cube are on a ramp now
so now that this thing's
inclined gravity is going to be exerting
an external force let's say it's at like
30 degrees
and if we graph the total momentum of
the ball and cube
it's not going to be a straight line
anymore it is not going to look like
this
that's what it looked like before when
there were no external forces this time
is going to be angled
up let's just call down the ramp
positive this time it's going to look
like this
gravity's pulling down the ramp let's
call that the positive direction if
we're measuring
the momentum in that parallel to the
ramp direction
we're going to see an increase in
momentum in that direction because
that's the way
that this external force of gravity
points
so how much will this increase how could
you figure out what the change
in the total momentum is going to be one
way to do it is to find the impulse so
remember
force times time would give you the
impulse let's just say
we were looking at this for about one
second of the time that these were on
the ramp
and let's say they have the values they
did before so 2 kilograms and
0.25 kilograms that would mean
the force down the ramp is mg sine theta
so the force
along this parallel direction is m which
the total mass of our system is 2.25
kilograms
so m times g 9.8
times sine of 30. so you need to take
the sine of 30 if you want to know the
change in momentum along this ramp
direction so the
force of gravity parallel is mg
sine theta and then that's the force so
that's the force parallel to the ramp
that would give us the
change in momentum parallel we just have
to multiply by the time which is one
second and that gives us about 11 units
of momentum so this system would gain
11 units of momentum that doesn't tell
you who's going to get it it's not like
the 2 gets all of it or the 0.25
gets all of it but the total system if
you watched for a second while it's on
this ramp frictionless ram
it would increase its momentum it'd be
changing its total momentum
because there was an external force so
recapping if there are no external
forces on a system
then the total momentum initial will
equal
the total momentum final so using p
equals
m v you can add up these contributions
and set them equal to problem solve
and in a case where there is an external
force you can find
how much the system will gain or lose in
momentum
by taking that external force times the
time that force was applied
that would give you the total change in
momentum of that system
over that time